From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Example number one. [BELL RINGS]
这里是芝加哥WBEZ电台的《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。例一。[钟声响起]
When she was 19, Lenore had a job selling tickets at a haunted mansion tourist attraction near Orlando, Florida. And one day she found in a stairwell a wallet someone dropped-- leather, she says, with a green rubber band, tons of cash inside, like a vacationer brings on a big trip.
19岁那年，勒诺在佛罗里达州奥兰多附近的一家鬼屋旅游景点卖票。一天，她在楼梯间发现了一个别人掉的钱包——她说那是个皮夹，上面还缠着根绿色橡皮筋，里面有成堆的现金，就像度假的人出远门带的那种。
It seemed obvious what to do next. She should figure out how to give it back. But two of the guys she worked with were like, let's not. Let's keep the money.
接下去该做什么显而易见。她应该想办法把钱包还回去。但她工作的两个同事却说，别还。咱们把钱留下吧。
And if they come back looking for it, we can say we don't have it. We didn't find it. And they'll never know. And I said, no, we have to return it. And they start telling me how ridiculous I'm being, and I'm such a goody two-shoes, and why am I like this?
如果失主回头来找，我们就说没捡到。我们没发现。他们永远不会知道。我说，不行，我们必须归还。他们就开始说我太可笑了，说我是个“乖乖女”，为什么我要这样？
Why? Who knows? But the one time that she tried shoplifting when she was 10 on a dare, she couldn't stand it, and returned the pack of gum and apologized. Lenore was also excited at the idea that she could be a hero, that the guy on the ID in the wallet would come in--
为什么？谁知道呢？但她10岁那年唯一一次在别人的怂恿下尝试顺手牵羊时，她心里过意不去，结果把那包口香糖退回去并道了歉。勒诺还为自己能成为英雄的想法感到兴奋，想象着钱包里身份证上的那个人会找上门来——
And be like, excuse me. Have you seen my wallet? And I'd say, Here, it is. And he'd be like, you're amazing! You saved the whole family's vacation. And he and his wife and kids would all cheer. And I'd bow and say thank you, and we'd hug.
然后说，打扰一下，你见到我的钱包了吗？我会说，在这儿呢。他会说，你太棒了！你挽救了我们全家的假期。然后他和他的妻子儿女会一起欢呼。我会鞠躬致谢，然后我们互相拥抱。
Remember, she's 19. So she tucks the wallet safely in her cash register drawer. Sure enough, a few hours later, the guy in the ID shows up. She very triumphantly pulls it out of the drawer.
别忘了，她当时19岁。于是她把钱包安全地藏在收银柜台的抽屉里。果然，几个小时后，身份证上的那个人出现了。她非常得意地把钱包从抽屉里拿出来。
And I said, here it is. And he grabs it out of my hands. And he starts rifling through it. And he looks through it and he says, some of the money is missing. And I just thought, no. No, I've had it the whole time. And he said, No, some of the money is missing. Did you take my money? You took my money.
我说，在这儿。他从我手里夺过钱包，开始翻找。他翻了一遍，然后说，钱少了。我当时心想，不，不可能。我一直都在好好保管。他说，不，钱就是少了。你拿了我的钱？是你拿了我的钱。
This is not going how she pictured. At all.
事情的发展和他想象的完全不一样。一点也不一样。
And my heart started racing. I started sweating. Why does he think I did this? He doesn't know me. I would never do that.
我的心开始狂跳。我开始冒汗。为什么他觉得是我干的？他根本不认识我。我绝不会做那种事。
He keeps berating her, insisting that she stole from him. It's awful. Finally, the guy's wife tells him to just let it go. And he turns and heads for the door.
他一直责骂她，坚持说她偷了他的钱。这太糟糕了。最后，那个人的妻子叫他算了。于是他转身朝门口走去。
And then as he was leaving, he said, you know, karma will find you. And I just stood there like, what happened? I don't get it. I did everything right.
就在他快离开时，他说，你知道吗，因果报应会找到你的。我只是站在那儿心想，发生了什么？我不明白。我做的一切都是对的。
She did everything right, and it didn't work out as planned. Ladies and gentlemen, there are so many examples of this. When we're kids, it's one of the hardest lessons we learn. [BELL RINGS] Example number two.
她做的一切都是对的，但结果却事与愿违。女士们先生们，这样的例子实在太多了。当我们还是孩子时，这是我们要上的最难的一课。[钟声响起] 例二。
So I am, I believe, 10 years old at the time.
所以当时我大概是10岁。
Jordan Pisarcik was, in fact, a lucky 10-year-old, because his parents got tickets to "the" tennis event in the United States-- the US Open. And he'd be seeing the number one player in the world. Jordan had been to baseball games with his parents, but not much tennis.
乔丹·皮萨奇克确实是个幸运的10岁孩子，因为他父母买到了美国“最”重大的网球赛事——美国网球公开赛的门票。他能见到世界排名第一的选手。乔丹以前和父母去看过棒球赛，但网球赛看得不多。
We sat down in the seat, and I said, oh, maybe we'll be able to catch a ball if they hit it out. It was Pete Sampras playing, who I was a big fan of. And so my father, he said, oh, this is-- tennis is not like baseball. You can't keep the ball the way you can if there's a home run or a foul ball. You have to throw it back as soon as you catch it. That's the rule in tennis.
我们坐下后我说，哦，也许如果他们把球打出界，我们能接住球。当时打球的是皮特·桑普拉斯，我是他的大粉丝。所以我爸爸说，哦，这不一样——网球不像棒球。你不能像接到全垒打球或界外球那样把球留下。你一接住就必须扔回去。这是网球的规矩。
And what felt like 10 to 15 minutes after that, a ball came heading right toward us out of play. My dad, who was a very tall man-- he's 6' 5"-- jumped up and grabbed the ball with one hand and pulled it back down.
大概在那之后的10到15分钟，一个球朝我们这边飞出了界。我父亲，一个非常高大的人——他有6英尺5英寸（约1.96米）——跳起来用一只手接住了球，然后拉回身前。
But his dad didn't throw the ball back. It made no sense. He'd just taught him the rule.
但他父亲并没有把球扔回去。这说不通。他刚刚才教过他规矩。
So of course I started saying, Dad, you're supposed to throw it back.
所以我当然开始说，爸爸，你应该把它扔回去。
Because are you kind of a rules follower kid?
因为你算是个循规蹈矩的孩子吗？
I would say I am, yes. And so I'm saying, Dad, you've got to throw it back. And he's kind of gesturing to me. It's fine. It's OK. Don't worry about it. It's fine. He's kind of holding it tight to him. And so finally, he kind of hands it over to me and says, here, just hold on to it. It's fine. And I said, no, you have to throw it back. And as I was saying that, I tossed the ball out. The ball starts flying. The ball lands squarely on the court while play is happening. And suddenly, of course, play immediately stops, and there's this audible gasp that rises from the crowd. It felt like all eyes were on me. So of course, I'm, like, melting into my seat.
我会说是的。所以我一直在说，爸爸，你得把它扔回去。他一直在向我做手势。没事的。没关系。别担心。没事的。他紧紧地护着球。最后，他把它递给我说，拿着吧，没事的。我说，不行，你必须把它扔回去。就在我说这话时，我把球扔了出去。球开始飞起来。球不偏不倚地落在了正在进行比赛的球场上。当然，比赛瞬间停止了，人群中发出了一阵清晰的惊呼声。感觉所有人的目光都集中在我身上。所以我当然恨不得钻进座位里。
Humiliated in front of all these people and Pete Sampras. You try to follow the rule. You try to do what's right. And see where you end up? [BELL RINGS] Example three.
在这么多人和皮特·桑普拉斯面前丢脸。你试着遵守规矩。你试着做正确的事。看看你最后落得什么下场？[钟声响起] 例三。
Morning, George.
早上好，乔治。
Morning, all.
大家早上好。
?] Hi, Ringo. Happy new year.
嗨，林戈。新年快乐。
?] Hi, George.
嗨，乔治。
?] Hi, Ringo. Happy new year.
嗨，林戈。新年快乐。
Apparently, this can also happen to you if you're one of the most successful, famous people in the world.
显然，即使你是世界上最成功、最出名的人之一，这种情况也会发生在你身上。
I won't lie. I'm not too good.
我不撒谎。我状态不太好。
Are you watching that new Beatles documentary series that Peter Jackson just put out where we see them trying to create 14 songs in just two weeks for the concert and album Let It Be? In episode 1, if you haven't seen this, George Harrison shows up at rehearsal on time every morning. John Lennon, by the way, usually late. George Harrison has brought songs that he's written. The band is desperate for songs, and he has songs. When he pulls them out, John and Paul do not seem enthusiastic.
你看了彼得·杰克逊刚出的那部披头士新纪录片系列了吗？在那里我们看到他们试图在短短两周内为《顺其自然》的演唱会和专辑创作14首歌。在第一集中，如果你没看过，乔治·哈里森每天早上都准时出现在排练现场。顺便说一句，约翰·列侬通常迟到。乔治·哈里森带来了他写的歌。乐队急需歌曲，而他确实有歌。当他拿出来时，约翰和保罗似乎并不热情。
Is this is a Harrisong?
这是一首哈里森的歌吗？
There's no solo or anything complicated.
没有独奏，也没有什么复杂的东西。
George walks them through the chord changes.
乔治引导他们练习和弦转换。
Oh, so the chords really are (SINGING) E to F-sharp minor to E to A.
哦，所以和弦真的是（唱）E到升F小调到E到A。
The song that he's teaching them is All Things Must Pass, which someday, after the Beatles break up, Harrison will release on his own, and it'll be a big hit. The album All Things Must Pass will be the number one album on the Billboard charts for seven weeks and receive near-universal critical praise. Harrison has done everything right.
他正在教他们的那首歌是《万物终将消逝》，这首歌在披头士解散后，哈里森将以个人身份发行，并成为一首热门歌曲。《万物终将消逝》专辑将连续七周位居公告牌排行榜榜首，并获得几乎普遍的好评。哈里森做的一切都是对的。
But in this room, it's not enough. He's completely overshadowed in these sessions by the kind of mind-blowing brilliance of Paul McCartney. If you've only seen one clip of this new documentary, it's probably this one that's made the rounds on social media. It starts with McCartney trying to invent a song out of nothing. And so he starts strumming chords, stumbles into fragments of what's going to be the Beatles single "Get Back."
但在那个房间里，这还不够。在这些排练中，他完全被保罗·麦卡特尼那种令人惊叹的才华所掩盖。如果你只看过这部新纪录片的一个片段，那很可能就是这个在社交媒体上流传的片段。它以麦卡特尼试图从零开始创作一首歌开始。于是他开始弹奏和弦，偶然组合出后来成为披头士单曲《回到过去》的片段。
[INDISTINCT SINGING]
[含糊不清的演唱]
Really within minutes, it seems like he conjures from nothing first the melody, then the chorus, then the verses of the song that most of us grew up with.
真的在几分钟内，他似乎凭空变出了这首歌的旋律、副歌，然后是歌词，而这首歌是我们大多数人耳熟能详的。
(SINGING) Get back, get back, get back to where you once belonged.
（唱）回到过去，回到过去，回到你曾经所属的地方。
By the end of the first episode of this TV documentary, Harrison has walked out of the rehearsals. And it's not clear that he's ever going to return. And who can blame him? He did it right. And Paul and John still don't want his song. It doesn't end up on a Beatles album.
在电视纪录片第一集结束时，哈里森已经离开了排练。目前还不清楚他是否还会回来。谁能怪他呢？他做得很对。但保罗和约翰还是不要他的歌。它最终没有出现在披头士的专辑中。
This is one of the most supremely confusing things that happens to us as people. We do what's right. We do what's asked. We follow the rules. We look out for others. We act responsibly. And it does not work out like we hoped.
这是作为人最令人困惑的事情之一。我们做正确的事。我们做被要求的事。我们遵守规则。我们为他人着想。我们负责任地行事。结果却不像我们预期的那样。
Today on our program, we see people in all sorts of situations puzzling out that ancient riddle in their own lives-- including, by the way, later in the hour, parents and children who purchase an ant farm. Stay with us.
今天在我们的节目中，我们将看到人们在各种情况下理清生活中那个古老的谜题——顺便提一下，在本小时稍后，还将提到购买蚂蚁农场的家长和孩子们。请继续收听。
Act One, "Damned If You Don't." So the person in this first story, Rebecca Shrader, is somebody, as you'll hear, who's very committed to doing the right thing in all parts of her life. She works as a sonographer. Ran one of the ultrasound machines at an OB clinic in Durham, North Carolina. Started about a decade ago.
第一幕，“不干也是死”。这个故事里的当事人丽贝卡·施拉德，正如你将听到的那样，是一个在生活方方面面都非常致力于做正确之事的人。她是一名超声波检查员。在北卡罗来纳州达勒姆的一家产科诊所操作超声波扫描仪，这份工作始于十年前。
She's great at her job, very diligent. And then, she saw something on her ultrasound screen and had to figure out what to do. By the way, throughout this story, we're going to use the words Rebecca typically uses around pregnancy and fetuses. She says the words "babies," "mothers," "women," though of course, those aren't the words everybody uses.
她工作非常出色，非常勤奋。然后，她在超声波屏幕上看到了一些东西，必须决定怎么做。顺便提一下，在整个故事中，我们将使用丽贝卡在怀孕和胎儿方面通常使用的词汇。她说“婴儿”、“母亲”、“女性”，尽管当然，这些词并不是每个人都用。
We found out about Rebecca from reporter Emma Green, who first talked to her a few years ago and has been reporting on religion and the way it intersects with politics for about a decade. Here's Emma.
我们是从记者艾玛·格林那里了解到丽贝卡的，她几年前第一次采访了她，并且在过去十年里一直在报道宗教及其与政治的交叉点。下面是艾玛的讲述。
It never really occurred to me that one of the perks of working in an obstetrics clinic is off-the-books access to an ultrasound machine. But Rebecca told me that lots of pregnant women have daydreamed about this scenario.
我从来没想过在产科诊所工作的好处之一就是可以私下使用超声波扫描仪。但丽贝卡告诉我，很多孕妇都幻想过这种情况。
I've had so many patients who have come to me and said, oh, if I had an ultrasound machine, I'd scan myself all the time. And you do, when you're pregnant and you're a sonographer. And so I would try to get into position, and try to straighten out and just scan myself standing up.
我有很多病人来找我说，哦，如果我有超声波机器，我会一直给自己扫描。当你怀孕并且是超声波检查员时，你就会这么做。所以我试着调整姿势，试着挺直身子，然后站着给自己做扫描。
What was that like?
那是什么样的感觉？
They obviously weren't the best images, but we could at least see a heart rate. And as long as I saw a heart rate, I was like, OK, we're good.
图像显然不是最好的，但我们至少能看到心跳。只要我能看到心跳，我就觉得，好，一切正常。
This was back in 2012, during Rebecca's first pregnancy. She was married, in her late 20s. She really wanted to be a mom. And it made her less anxious to be able to see what was happening with her baby.
那是2012年，丽贝卡第一次怀孕期间。她已婚，快30岁。她非常想成为一名母亲。能够看到婴儿的情况让她减少了焦虑。
Rebecca knew exactly what could go wrong in a pregnancy because the clinic where she worked at Duke specialized in complicated and risky pregnancies, things like chromosomal abnormalities or pregnancies with a high possibility of miscarriage or stillbirth. Just to warn listeners, issues like this are going to come up a lot in this story. At work, she prided herself especially on taking really good 3D images with tons of detail.
丽贝卡非常清楚怀孕期间会出现什么问题，因为她工作的杜克大学诊所专门处理复杂和高风险的妊娠，比如染色体异常或流产、死产可能性较高的妊娠。给听众提个醒，这类问题在这个故事中会经常出现。在工作中，她尤其以能拍出细节丰富、效果极佳的3D图像而自豪。
And I would do it while the baby was moving. And so it really helped women. I could see them getting emotional watching it on the screen, knowing that maybe my baby might have some disability, but that's OK, because that gave them hope to see that I'm going to love this baby regardless of whether they have a disability or whether they maybe don't survive birth.
我会趁孩子活动时拍。这真的很有帮助。我能看到她们在屏幕上看着图像时变得情绪激动，意识到也许我的孩子可能有些残疾，但没关系，因为看到我无论孩子是否有残疾，或者即使他们可能没能活下来，都会依然爱这个孩子，这给了她们希望。
Working in an OB clinic made sense for Rebecca. She's from a family of scientists and doctors. And she always loved babies. But her love for her work also came from her faith. She was a member of Summit, one of the most prominent Southern Baptist megachurches in the country. And she believes life begins at conception. Every tiny heartbeat she saw on the ultrasound screen was a living human being.
在产科诊所工作对丽贝卡来说是有意义的。她来自一个科学和医生家庭。她一直很喜欢婴儿。但她对工作的热爱也源于她的信仰。她是“峰会”教堂的成员，这是全国最著名的美南浸信会大型教堂之一。她相信生命始于受孕。她在超声波屏幕上看到的每一个微小的心跳都是一个活生生的人。
She thought abortion was morally wrong. She even spent her Thursday nights volunteering at a crisis pregnancy center. These centers are the pro-life movement's answer to Planned Parenthood. They're designed to discourage women from getting abortions. And they do things like provide free diapers, and parenting classes, and ultrasounds. That's what Rebecca helped with.
她认为堕胎在道德上是错误的。她甚至把周四晚上的时间花在危机妊娠中心做志愿者。这些中心是反堕胎运动对“计划生育”组织的回应。它们旨在阻止女性堕胎。它们做些提供免费尿布、育儿课程和超声波之类的工作。这就是丽贝卡帮忙做的事情。
So anyways, those free ultrasounds Rebecca gave herself-- once she was pregnant going through this new experience, she developed this Monday morning ritual at work. She'd head straight to her ultrasound room, stand up in front of her screen, squirt jelly on her abdomen, and grab the probe, which looks a little bit like a Nintendo Wii controller. Here's what she saw. Week six, the flicker of a heartbeat. Week seven, little arm buds. Week nine, toes.
总之，丽贝卡给自己做的那些免费超声波——一旦她怀孕经历了这种新体验，她在工作中就养成了一种周一早上的仪式。她会径直走进她的超声波室，站在屏幕前，在腹部挤上凝胶，拿起探头，看起来有点像任天堂Wii的遥控器。这是她看到的：第6周，心跳的闪烁。第7周，小小的手臂芽。第9周，脚趾。
And then when I got to the 10th week, I was scanning myself, and I noticed there was some fluid on the back of the neck. And I noticed that there was a bulge kind of right by the abdomen.
然后到了第10周，我给自己做扫描时，发现脖子后面有一些积液。我注意到腹部旁边有一个肿块。
Rebecca went to find one of the doctors she worked with. Her boss came too, to do another scan.
丽贝卡去找她的一位同事医生。她的老板也来了，做了另一次扫描。
I know. I know the looks between doctors and sonographers. I know what those mean. They weren't going to hide anything from me.
我知道，我知道医生和检查员之间的眼神交流。我知道那意味着什么。他们不会向我隐瞒任何事情。
?] Which was-- what did you see?
那你看到了什么？
Just them looking at each other, and just kind of an unease between the two of them, knowing that there was something definitely really wrong, but we weren't sure exactly what it was, which is what the doctor told me. It was just kind of like a drop-- my stomach dropped.
只是他们看着对方，两人之间有一种不安，知道确实出了什么严重的问题，但我们不确定到底是什么，这也是医生告诉我的。我感觉胃里沉了一下。
Rebecca and her husband, Josh, eventually got a likely diagnosis-- limb-body wall complex. This is extremely rare. By 15 weeks, most of the baby's organs-- the stomach, liver, intestines-- were hanging outside of the abdomen. The baby's spine was bent at a 90-degree angle.
丽贝卡和她的丈夫乔什最终得到了一个可能的诊断——肢体-体壁综合征。这极其罕见。到15周时，胎儿的大部分器官——胃、肝脏、肠道——都悬挂在腹部外面。胎儿的脊椎呈90度弯曲。
Those anomalies were enough to know that either the baby was going to have thousands of surgeries when it was born alive, or it could end up being stillborn. I think they said most babies don't live to be a year old. So there's very rare circumstances that the baby even lived a few days or months. But there was no record of a baby of being over a year old.
这些异常足以说明，要么孩子出生后需要进行成千上万次手术，要么可能是死产。我想他们说大多数孩子活不过一岁。所以即便能活几天或几个月的情况也极罕见。但没有超过一岁的记录。
They had to decide what to do. Rebecca knew her doctor might bring up abortion.
他们必须决定怎么做。丽贝卡知道她的医生可能会提出堕胎。
Do you remember how that conversation went with your doctors?
你还记得你和医生之间是如何进行那次谈话的吗？
Yeah, so we had sat down and she said, I know-- they all knew what my personal beliefs were. And so she said, I know normally what you would choose. You might choose to carry to term. But since this is such a low risk of survival, what are you thinking now? This is likely going to end in the baby dying at some point, either before birth or after birth. They still gave me that option to terminate.
记得，我们坐下来，她说，我知道——他们都知道我的个人信仰。所以她说，我知道你通常会怎么选择。你可能会选择足月生产。但既然存活风险这么低，你现在是怎么想的？这很可能以胎儿在某个时刻死亡告终，要么在出生前，要么在出生后。他们仍然给了我终止妊娠的选项。
Do you remember how you internally reacted to that suggestion?
你还记得你内心对那个建议的反应吗？
Kind of dismissively, I guess. It wasn't even on the table, in my eyes.
比较排斥吧，我想。在我看来，那根本不在考虑范围内。
How did your husband react?
你丈夫的反应是什么？
Similar. Very like, oh, we're going to carry to term. We were pretty much on the same page.
一样。非常坚定地认为，哦，我们要足月生产。我们意见相当统一。
She would carry the baby as long as she could, even though it would have been safer for her own health to terminate. Generally speaking, pregnancy and delivery carry a lot of inherent risks. But Rebecca believed she had to give her baby a chance. There was a purpose for her baby's life, even if Rebecca didn't quite know what it was yet.
她会尽可能长地怀着孩子，即使终止妊娠对她自己的健康更安全。一般来说，怀孕和分娩本身就带有许多内在风险。但丽贝卡相信她必须给孩子一个机会。她的孩子的生活是有目的的，即使丽贝卡当时还不完全知道那是什么。
It wasn't her place to change the course of her pregnancy. As a sonographer, she knew there was basically no possibility that her baby would be born alive and survive. But as a Christian, she felt she had to be faithful and keep praying hard that God would intervene.
改变怀孕进程不是她的立场。作为一名超声波检查员，她知道她的孩子基本上没有活下来并生存的可能。但作为一名基督徒，她觉得她必须保持忠诚，继续虔诚地祈祷上帝会介入。
There was a tiny bit of hope still there. I do feel like so many people saying, I'm praying for a miracle and stuff, did give me a little bit of hope maybe the baby would survive.
依然有一丝微弱的希望。我觉得有很多人说，我在祈求奇迹之类的话，确实给了我一点希望，也许孩子能活下来。
Do you feel like you needed that little sliver of hope in order to continue carrying?
你觉得你是否需要那一丝希望才能继续怀下去？
I do believe that I probably craved it, especially being visibly pregnant and scanning people every day. And everyone's asking me-- every patient that I have is asking me about it. Are you having a boy or girl? And do you have a nursery already? And all of that stuff. So I do feel like I kind of held on to hope for a little bit.
我相信我可能渴望它，特别是在显怀的时候，每天给别人做扫描。每个人都在问我——我的每个病人都问我。你怀的是男孩还是女孩？你已经布置好婴儿房了吗？诸如此类。所以我确实觉得我一直坚持希望了一段时间。
In a strange way, she wasn't surprised that something had gone terribly wrong with her pregnancy. Rebecca always had this feeling in the back of her mind like God was going to use her or test her in some way, because she worked at a place where most of her coworkers were pro-choice and where the doctors referred patients to get abortions at a nearby clinic all the time.
奇怪的是，她并不惊讶怀孕出了大问题。丽贝卡脑海深处总有种感觉，上帝会以某种方式使用她或考验她，因为她在一家大部分同事都支持堕胎、且医生经常把病人转介到附近诊所进行堕胎的地方工作。
Rebecca started a blog called "Afflictions Eclipsed By Glory," a line from a popular Christian song. She made it to share all of the complicated medical details she was sorting through with her family and friends. But she also hoped it would reach beyond her circle with a specific message.
丽贝卡开了一个名为“荣耀遮蔽下的苦难”的博客，这出自一首流行的基督教歌曲。她写这个博客是为了分享她正在与家人和朋友梳理的所有复杂的医学细节。但她也希望它能带着特定的信息传达给圈子之外的人。
I do feel like I wanted to empower women by saying, I made this choice. And if you feel like you can, then I'm telling you I did it so that maybe you feel like you can do it too. And I just wanted to be used by God in whatever way he had me. So I just kind of wrote every blog with very honest feelings.
我确实觉得我想通过说“我做出了这个选择”来赋予女性力量。如果你觉得你可以做到，那我告诉你我做到了，这样也许你也会觉得你可以做到。我只是想以上帝想要我采取的任何方式被祂使用。所以我写每一篇博客时都带着非常诚实的感受。
In one of her entries, she wrote, quote, "You may not notice, but I cry a lot. Usually alone in my car, apartment, or ultrasound room, but always silent and always in control." At 18 weeks, Rebecca and Josh announced on their blog that they were having a girl. They named her Cora Kimberly.
在其中一篇博文中，她写道：“你可能没注意到，但我经常哭。通常是在车里、公寓里或超声波室里独自哭泣，但总是沉默且总是克制着。”在18周时，丽贝卡和乔什在他们的博客上宣布他们怀的是个女孩。他们给她取名叫科拉·金伯利。
Rebecca came to see her pregnancy as a personal cross that would provide some inevitable redemption. And this idea was reflected back to her at church. When Rebecca first started going to Summit, it felt really large. But she volunteered in the baby room during services, and got to know people, and found this group of women who she could really talk to-- her small group. That's the term in evangelical-speak for the people she prayed with every week.
丽贝卡开始把怀孕视为一种个人的十字架，将带来某种不可避免的救赎。这种想法在教会里也得到了反映。丽贝卡第一次去“峰会”教堂时，觉得它非常大。但她在主日崇拜期间在婴儿室做志愿者，认识了很多人，并找到了这群她可以真正交流的女性——她的小组。这就是福音派中她每周一起祈祷的人的称呼。
These were her closest friends in Durham, the people who invited her and her husband to baseball games and had them over to their houses for cookouts. When Rebecca shared the latest on her pregnancy, they'd tell her how strong she was. People knew the Shraders when they walked into church.
她们是她在达勒姆最亲密的朋友，那些邀请她和丈夫去看棒球赛、邀请他们去家里烧烤的人。当丽贝卡分享她怀孕的最新消息时，她们会告诉她她是多么坚强。施拉德夫妇走进教堂时，人们都知道他们。
They'd sometimes stop Rebecca in the halls and say they'd read her blog, and they were praying for her. At Summit, she was like this pro-life darling. One Monday in her third trimester, Rebecca went into work and started her week like she always did-- alone in her ultrasound room, running the probe over her belly.
有时人们会在走廊里拦住丽贝卡，说他们读过她的博客，正在为她祈祷。在“峰会”教堂，她是反堕胎运动的宠儿。在怀孕第三个季度的某个周一，丽贝卡去上班，像往常一样开始她的一周——独自在她的超声波室里，把探头在肚皮上滑动。
And I saw that she didn't have a heartbeat, and it was just-- all of a sudden, everything became surreal at that point. One of my first thoughts was, now I'm going to have to go through labor to deliver her, and she's not going to be alive.
然后我发现她没有心跳了，这真是——那一刻突然一切都变得离奇了。我最初的想法之一是，现在我得经历分娩把她生下来，而她却不会是活着的。
Thinking about everything she was about to have to do made her incredibly anxious.
想到所有她即将必须做的事情让她感到无比焦虑。
I've never labored before. This is my first baby. And then I was going to hold her, and I had no idea-- I hadn't held my own baby, ever. And so here I am, I'm going to hold a baby who's no longer living. And so it was just a lot of feeling of dread.
我以前从没分娩过。这是我的第一个孩子。然后我必须抱着她，而我一点头绪也没有——我从来没抱过我自己的孩子。所以现在我在这里，我将要抱一个不再活着的婴儿。这真是充满了恐惧的感觉。
At the hospital, doctors gave Rebecca a drug to start her labor. Church friends were in the room when she started pushing. Cora was so tiny-- just 1 pound, 2 ounces-- that it only took about five minutes for Rebecca to deliver her. The room was silent. Later that day, two pastors from Summit came by to pray with Rebecca. They read her verses from the book of Lamentations.
在医院，医生给了丽贝卡一种催产药物。当她开始用力时，教会的朋友们就在房间里。科拉非常娇小——只有1磅2盎司（约510克）——所以丽贝卡只花了大约五分钟就生下了她。房间里一片寂静。那天晚些时候，“峰会”教堂的两位牧师过来和丽贝卡一起祈祷。他们为她读了《耶利米哀歌》中的经文。
I don't even really remember crying that much when I was in the room, I think, because I was surrounded by so many other people. And I just didn't allow myself that moment of grief until everyone had left, and I was by myself at night.
我甚至不记得在房间里哭得有多厉害，我想，因为我被这么多其他人包围着。直到大家都走了，晚上只剩下我一个人时，我才让自己释放了那种悲伤。
Did you still, in this moment, feel that God was using you?
在这一刻，你仍然觉得上帝在使用你吗？
I mean, I felt like I was completely still kind of in shock, I guess, in the moment. But I felt like maybe God was using me in a way that I didn't even know yet.
我的意思是，我觉得自己当时可能还完全处于震惊之中。但我感觉也许上帝正在以我甚至还不知道的方式使用我。
Cora's headstone bears the title of the classic hymn It Is Well With My Soul. Rebecca got the same phrase tattooed on the underside of her wrist. After Cora died, Rebecca and her husband decided to adopt a kid. This is pretty common in the evangelical and pro-life worlds. And it was something her church really supported.
科拉的墓碑上刻着经典赞美诗《我心灵得安宁》的标题。丽贝卡在手腕内侧纹了同样的短语。科拉去世后，丽贝卡和她的丈夫决定领养一个孩子。这在福音派和反堕胎世界中很常见。这也是她教会非常支持的事情。
And while they were going through this process, they also started trying for another pregnancy. It happened fast. Rebecca's due date was just a couple of weeks before the first anniversary of Cora's death. She scanned herself every week, just like she had done with Cora. But this time, everything was perfect.
在他们进行这个过程的同时，他们也开始尝试再次怀孕。进展很快。丽贝卡的预产期就在科拉去世一周年纪念日的前几周。她每周都给自己做扫描，就像对科拉做的一样。但这一次，一切都很完美。
I was a little anxious, but she came early. So that was helpful. She came at 38 and 1/2 weeks, so I didn't have to worry too, too long. And my labor was really easy and good. And everything about it was great. And so when she came out, it was just all joy. And so I thought maybe this is my gift after being through something so horrible.
我有点焦虑，但她早产了。这很有帮助。她在38周半时出生，所以我不用担心太久。我的分娩非常顺利和轻松。关于她的一切都很棒。所以当她出来时，一切都充满了喜悦。于是我想也许这是我经历如此可怕的事情后的礼物。
They named her Lydia. She was their rainbow baby, which is what the pregnancy loss world calls a birth after a miscarriage, stillbirth, or infant death-- this glimpse of brightness. People at her church were extra excited for her. They told her and Josh how much they deserved it. And then, the adoption went through. The Shraders' son, Aben, came to North Carolina from Ethiopia. He was about two years older than Lydia. The Shraders wanted a big family, something like four kids. They bought a minivan.
他们给她取名叫莉迪亚。她是他们的“彩虹宝宝”，这就是怀孕流产、死产或婴儿死亡后出生的孩子——那一抹光明。她教会里的人对她格外兴奋。他们告诉她和乔什他们是多么值得拥有这一切。然后，领养手续办妥了。施拉德夫妇的儿子阿本从埃塞俄比亚来到了北卡罗来纳州。他比莉迪亚大两岁左右。施拉德夫妇想要一个大家庭，大概四个孩子。他们买了一辆小型货车。
But little by little, in the background of all of that life unfolding, Rebecca was thinking about her pro-life stance and questioning it. Her questions came from little observations, things she felt in her body. Like after losing Cora, Rebecca learned that the drug doctors use to inducer labor is also used in some abortion procedures. And Rebecca realized that some women who had abortions-- some, but not all-- were part of the very small group who could viscerally understand one of the hardest parts of what she went through-- laboring to deliver a body that will never cry out.
但一点一点地，在所有这些生活展开的背景下，丽贝卡开始思考她的反堕胎立场并质疑它。她的疑问来自一些小的观察，她身体感受到的事情。比如在失去科拉后，丽贝卡了解到医生用来诱导分娩的药物也用于某些堕胎手术。丽贝卡意识到，一些做过堕胎手术的女性——不是所有人，但其中一些——是极少数能够直观理解她所经历的最困难部分的人之一——分娩出一个永远不会哭泣的身体。
It made me realize that for a lot of people-- not for everybody, but for a lot of people, abortion can be a very traumatic, unwanted procedure that they feel like they have no choice to go through. And that's kind of how I felt like I was going through this birth. I didn't want to deliver her. I didn't want to deliver her body. I didn't want to have to go through that.
这让我意识到，对于很多人——不是所有人，但对于很多人来说，堕胎可能是一个非常痛苦、不想要的程序，她们觉得别无选择。这和我经历这次分娩的感觉有点像。我不想生下她。我不想生下她的尸体。我不想经历这一切。
The strangeness of that shared experience started to make her feel a new kind of empathy for women who'd had abortions. Her pro-life world at Summit started looking different to her. The way people talked about abortion was so black and white, and she was starting to see some gray. But she knew she couldn't say anything about all of this at church.
这种共同经历的奇异感开始让她对做过堕胎的女性产生了一种新的同情。她在“峰会”教堂的反堕胎世界开始对她显得不同了。人们谈论堕胎的方式是如此黑白分明，而她开始看到一些灰色地带。但她知道她在教会里不能对这一切发表任何看法。
In 2017, Rebecca found out she was pregnant a third time. And seven weeks in, scanning herself, she noticed something was wrong with the baby's head. Against all odds, the worst thing was happening, again-- another pregnancy with a fatal diagnosis. This time, anencephaly, an extremely rare disorder where parts of the brain and skull are missing or develop abnormally. Babies with this diagnosis are usually stillborn or die within a couple of hours or days. There's no chance of survival.
2017年，丽贝卡发现自己第三次怀孕了。在7周时，扫描自己时，她注意到胎儿的头部出了问题。违背一切几率，最坏的事情又发生了——又一次致命诊断的妊娠。这一次是无脑畸形，一种极其罕见的疾病，部分大脑和颅骨缺失或发育异常。被诊断出患有此病的婴儿通常是死产或在几小时或几天内死亡。没有存活的可能。
How did it feel to have another challenging diagnosis? Did you feel like God was playing a joke on you? Did you feel like you were just profoundly unlucky? What was that like, to be there again?
又一次面临挑战性的诊断感觉如何？你是否觉得上帝在和你开玩笑？你觉得你只是非常不幸吗？再次身处这种境地是什么感觉？
I was like, maybe God put me in this situation again to, I don't know, test me, or show Himself again. But why did He have to do it this way? I was mad that we were doing this again. I was mad that I was going to-- I was almost mad that I was going to have to choose life. Like, I wanted to, but I was also mad at the decision that I was having to make, it felt like. Because this was different than Cora. I didn't have any hope. There wasn't any hope.
我觉得，也许上帝再次把我置于这种境地，我不不知道，是为了考验我，或再次显现祂自己。但为什么祂非要这样对待我？我因为我们再次经历这些而愤怒。我很愤怒我不得不——我几乎很愤怒我不得不“选择生命”。就像，我想那么做，但我同时也对自己不得不做出的决定感到愤怒，感觉是这样的。因为这和科拉的情况不同。我没有任何希望。没有任何希望。
Doctors later told Rebecca there wasn't any genetic or medical explanation for why she and Josh had two pregnancies that went so wrong. They just got very, very unlucky. They had to sit down again with a doctor to talk about what to do. It ended up being the same doctor who had talked them through their decision with Cora.
医生后来告诉丽贝卡，她和乔什两次怀孕都出了这么大的问题没有任何遗传或医学解释。他们只是非常、非常不幸。他们不得不再次坐下来和医生商量怎么做。最终是同一位医生，她曾与他们谈过关于科拉的决定。
She said the same thing again. She was like, I know that you carried to term before. I don't want to assume-- because I remember this. She said, I don't want to assume that you're going to carry to term again. She was like, so I just want to put termination on the table. She was like, and if you need to talk about it, I can be here to talk about it. If you want to talk about it with just your husband alone, you can do that.
她再次说了同样的话。她说，我知道你以前选择了足月生产。我不想假设——因为我记得这个。她说，我不想假设你会再次选择足月生产。她说，所以我想把终止妊娠放在桌面上。她说，如果你需要谈谈，我可以留下来谈。如果你想只和丈夫私下谈，也可以。
And I remember looking over at my husband like, me saying, yes, we're going to carry to term, and him saying at the same time, I don't know. We both said it at the same time. The doctor noticed that we both said different things, stepped out, and we had a conversation right then and there about it.
我记得看向我丈夫，像是说，是的，我们要足月生产，而他同时说，我不知道。我们同时说了不同的话。医生注意到我们意见分歧，走了出去，我们当场就此事进行了谈话。
And I guess I felt like I couldn't live with myself if I personally chose knowing that I had done this before. What would I be saying? Would I be saying Cora was more worthy, that I like this baby more than this baby? Or this baby deserves a chance and this one didn't? And he was like, I don't know if we can do this again.
我想我觉得如果我个人选择（终止），而我知道我以前做过一次，我就没法面对自己。我会说什么呢？我会说科拉更值得吗，我喜欢这个孩子胜过那个孩子？或者这个孩子值得一个机会而那个孩子不值得？他说，我不知道我们能否再经历一次。
Eventually, they decided together that Rebecca would continue the pregnancy. They also gave this baby a name, Layla Kate. But Rebecca's pregnancy with Layla was very different from the one she had with Cora. Back then, she talked with her small group at church constantly about what was going on with Cora and how she was feeling. With Layla, she didn't really want to talk about it at all.
最终，他们共同决定丽贝卡将继续怀孕。他们也给这个孩子取了名字，莱拉·凯特。但丽贝卡怀莱拉的过程和怀科拉时非常不同。那时，她经常和教会的小组谈论科拉的情况以及她的感受。怀莱拉时，她真的不想谈论它。
Rebecca spent most of her days at work trying to dissociate from what was happening. But she couldn't ignore it entirely. Layla was way more active than Cora, kicking and tumbling around. For a while, Rebecca stopped reading the Bible. She couldn't pray. She couldn't sing hymns.
丽贝卡大部分时间都在试图与正在发生的事情剥离。但她无法完全忽视它。莱拉比科拉活跃得多，踢来踢去。有一段时间，丽贝卡停止阅读《圣经》。她无法祈祷。她无法唱赞美诗。
I grieved with Cora in a sad way. When Layla came along, I came out more in a rage.
我以一种悲伤的方式哀悼科拉。当莱拉到来时，我以更愤怒的方式爆发出来。
What does that mean?
那是什么意思？
I remember a very specific incident where I was doing laundry. I started freaking out and throwing the laundry. And then I ended up punching the dresser and jamming my finger. And it was just-- I had just held it in for so long, being at work, trying to hold it in, holding all my emotions. It all came out at one time. And of course, it was at home. So it happened kind of in front of my kids and stuff. And they were confused as to why I was so yelling and angry. And I was like, I just can't pretend. My pretending was just at a-- we were at a limit.
我记得一件非常具体的事情，当时我正在洗衣服。我开始崩溃，扔衣服。然后我对着梳妆台猛打一拳，撞伤了手指。这只是——我憋得太久了，在工作中，试图忍住，压抑所有情绪。它一次性爆发了。当然，是在家里。所以它是在我的孩子们面前发生的。他们很困惑我为什么大喊大叫和生气。我当时想，我只是无法伪装了。我的伪装已经到了极限。
The thing Rebecca wanted most of all, her number one prayer request, was to hold Layla alive after she was born. She became hyper-focused on the idea that Layla's organs could be donated to medical research. She was grasping for a sense of purpose, still hoping she would get some kind of redemption. And then one night, roughly a week before she was scheduled to be induced, she felt like something was off.
丽贝卡最想要的东西，她首要的祈祷请求，就是在莱拉出生后还能抱着活着的她。她变得过于专注于莱拉的器官可以捐献给医学研究的想法。她仍在抓取一种目的感，希望能得到某种救赎。然后在一个晚上，大约在她预产期前一周，她感觉有些不对劲。
And I was like, well, maybe she's just tired and doesn't want to move. Maybe this is just a day she doesn't move. And I went into work-- even though I wasn't supposed to be at work-- I went in to scan myself because I just couldn't handle the anxiety. And that's when I found out that she didn't have a heartbeat. It almost felt like an immediate rejection, and like my prayer hadn't been heard. And I felt like I asked for so little in these big situations. And I felt like I didn't get it.
我就想，也许她只是累了不想动。也许这只是她不动的一天。我去了医院——即使我本不该上班——我进去扫描自己，因为我实在无法承受这种焦虑。就在那时我发现她没有心跳了。感觉几乎像是一种直接的拒绝，就像我的祈祷没有被听见。我觉得在这些大事中我求得这么少。我觉得我没有得到它。
Because Layla wasn't born alive, her organs couldn't be donated. The family buried her in a plot near Cora. When Rebecca returned to work after Layla's death, it felt good to be back at first. She felt especially drawn to helping families who knew their babies were not going to survive, so the doctors specifically gave those cases to her.
因为莱拉出生时不是活着的，所以她的器官无法捐献。家人把她埋在靠近科拉的一块墓地里。莱拉去世后丽贝卡回到工作岗位，起初感觉还不错。她感到特别被吸引去帮助那些知道孩子无法存活的家庭，所以医生专门把这些病例交给了她。
But her grief was persistent, a debilitating fog in her head. All day, every day, she performed ultrasounds in the very same room where she had discovered that both Cora and Layla's heartbeats had stopped. There's this picture of tulips, her favorite flower, in her ultrasound room. She used to love it. But now it was a constant reminder of what she had lost.
但她的悲伤持续不断，大脑中笼罩着令人虚弱的迷雾。每天，每一天，她都在同一个房间进行超声波检查，她就是在那里发现科拉和莱拉的心跳都停止了。在她的超声波室里有一幅郁金香的画，那是她最喜欢的花。她曾经很喜欢它。但现在它不断提醒她失去了什么。
Just seeing the ultrasound machine and being in that room was enough to make me nervous. My heart would race when I had to take a patient in sometimes. I was always fearful that the same thing was going to happen. I was going to scan somebody who had a surprise abnormality, and I was going to have to tell them. I just didn't-- I didn't want to go through those feelings again.
只要看到超声波机器并待在那个房间里就足以让我紧张。有时当我要带病人进来时，我的心会狂跳。我总是害怕同样的事情会发生。我会扫描到某个有意外异常的病人，而我不得不告诉她们。我只是不想——不想再经历那些感受。
Rebecca got a therapist, went on depression meds. But after an entire year of feeling so unsteady at work, she decided she actually had to leave her job. She found a new position at a regular OB clinic, where the patients were mostly young, and healthy, and had uncomplicated pregnancies. On her blog, she posted a picture of herself holding a pill in her open hand. The entry is titled, "It's OK to Have Jesus and a Therapist Too." You can see Cora and Layla's names tattooed on her wrist below that phrase, "It Is Well With My Soul."
丽贝卡请了治疗师，服用了抗抑郁药物。但在工作中感到如此不稳定整整一年后，她决定确实必须辞职。她在一家普通的产科诊所找到了新职位，那里的病人大多年轻、健康，妊娠过程没有复杂情况。她在博客上贴了一张自己张开的手中拿着药片的照片。文章标题是，“有耶稣和治疗师相伴也是可以的”。你可以在那个“我心灵得安宁”的短语下看到她手腕上纹着的科拉和莱拉的名字。
This time around, Rebecca really felt like she wanted to talk openly about how hard and painful all of this had been. She saw an opportunity to speak publicly at this event her church holds called, Sanctity of Life Sunday. Lots of conservative churches use Sanctity of Life Sunday each year to preach about the pro-life cause.
这一次，丽贝卡确实觉得她想公开谈论这一切有多么艰难和痛苦。她看到了一个在教会举办的名为“生命尊严周日”的活动上公开发言的机会。许多保守派教会在每年使用“生命尊严周日”来宣讲反堕胎事业。
I did, many times, reach out to our church and say, hey, Sanctity of Life Sunday is coming up. I would be happy to speak out, and this is my story. And I sent that to our head pastor and many of the other pastors, and it was never brought up or answered. It was just amazing to me that I had been through this twice. I could go up there and speak about it. And I was in the church. I was a member of the church, and they never asked me to.
我确实多次联系我们的教会并说，嘿，生命尊严周日就要到了。我很乐意站出来谈谈，这是我的故事。我把它发给了我们的主任牧师和其他许多牧师，但从未被提起或回答。这让我感到惊讶，我经历过两次这种情况。我可以上台谈论它。我当时在教会里。我是教会的一员，而他们从来没邀请过我。
I asked some leaders at Summit about this, including a lead pastor. And they said that they're often choosing from multiple stories and don't have enough time at services for each one to be shared. But Rebecca believes she wasn't given a chance to speak because only a certain kind of woman gets featured at Sanctity of Life Sunday, the woman who chose life, sometimes against doctor's advice, and certainly against all odds, and God rewarded her for her faith.
我问了一些“峰会”教堂的领导人关于这件事，包括一位主任牧师。他们说他们经常要在多个故事中进行选择，服务时间不够分享每一个故事。但丽贝卡认为她没有得到发言的机会，因为只有特定类型的女性才能在“生命尊严周日”上亮相，那些选择了生命、有时违背医生建议、当然也违背一切几率的女性，而上帝奖励了她们的信仰。
She was given some heart-wrenching diagnosis, but her baby was born completely fine. Or as she was told her son would have severe disabilities, but here he is at church, thriving as an adult. With Cora, Rebecca easily fit into this archetype. Her church community rallied around her with their prayers and their presence. And she did get her redemption story in a way, with Lydia arriving so soon after Cora's death, and Aben's adoption not too long after that. But now, Rebecca felt like her life no longer fit a clean redemption storyline.
她得到了一些令人心碎的诊断，但她的孩子出生时完全健康。或者像她被告知她的儿子会有严重残疾，但现在他出现在教会，作为一个成年人茁壮成长。对于科拉，丽贝卡很容易符合这种原型。她的教会社区用他们的祈祷和陪伴支持她。在某种程度上，她确实得到了她的救赎故事，莉迪亚在科拉去世后很快到来，阿本的领养也不久之后完成。但现在，丽贝卡觉得她的生活不再符合一个干净的救赎故事情节。
I can't imagine going up there at the front of the church saying, this is what happened, and then my baby died. And then it was really hard, and I was really depressed and mad at God. They didn't want to be told that it was hard. They wanted to hear me, when I was with Cora saying, I had hope, and I was OK. But I think my grief after Layla was way more authentic than it was after Cora. And people felt uncomfortable about that.
我无法想象站在教会前面说，发生了这些事，然后我的孩子死了。然后这非常艰难，我非常抑郁，对上帝很生气。他们不想被告知这很艰难。他们想听我分享的是，我和科拉在一起时说，我有希望，我很好。但我认为我在莱拉之后的悲伤比在科拉之后更真实。而人们对此感到不舒服。
To be clear, Summit leaders say they don't only want to hear happy stories. But that's not how Rebecca sees it. When her experience of making a pro-life decision got more complicated, when she felt more ambivalence, it was like they didn't want anything to do with her. Rebecca was feeling incredibly alienated in the pro-life world.
明确地说，“峰会”教堂的领导人说他们不只想听快乐的故事。但这并不是丽贝卡眼中的样子。当她做出反堕胎决定的经历变得更复杂时，当她感到更多矛盾心理时，就像他们不想和她有任何瓜葛。丽贝卡在反堕胎世界里感到无比疏远。
But she slowly started to realize that other evangelical women were feeling the same way. They were coming to her, quietly-- sometimes at church, sometimes online-- telling her their stories, messy ones that also wouldn't make the stage at Sanctity of Life Sunday. There was this one woman from church named Jen. She was pretty involved at Summit. Rebecca first met her when they were both helping with child care during Sunday services.
但她慢慢开始意识到其他福音派女性也有同样的感觉。她们悄悄地来到她身边——有时在教会，有时在线上——告诉她她们的故事，那些混乱的、同样无法登上“生命尊严周日”舞台的故事。教会里有个叫珍的女性。她在“峰会”教堂相当投入。丽贝卡第一次见到她是在她们都在主日崇拜期间帮忙照顾孩子的时候。
They had a lot in common. Jen also grew up in a really conservative Christian world, really wanted to be a mom. When she got pregnant for the first time, she also got this diagnosis that came out of nowhere-- Trisomy 13, a rare condition with little chance of survival. When Rebecca heard about Jen's situation through the grapevine at church, she immediately thought about what she'd been through with Cora and Layla. But Rebecca learned that Jen might be considering an abortion. Rebecca texted her.
她们有很多共同点。珍也在一个非常保守的基督教世界中长大，非常想成为一名母亲。当她第一次怀孕时，也收到了这个突如其来的诊断——13-三体综合征，一种存活率极低的罕见疾病。当丽贝卡通过教会的传闻听说珍的情况时，她立即想到了她和科拉、莱拉的经历。但丽贝卡了解到珍可能在考虑堕胎。丽贝卡给珍发了短信。
I had said something like, regardless of the choice you make, I'm here with you. If you need to call me and vent, or need to talk to me, just know I'm safe.
我说了一些类似的话，无论你做出什么选择，我都和你在一起。如果你需要打电话给我发泄，或需要跟我谈谈，只知道我是安全的。
They didn't know each other very well back then, but Jen told me Rebecca's message allowed her to admit to herself that she might get an abortion, and it would be OK if she did. Ultimately, Jen chose to terminate her pregnancy. Afterwards, at church, Jen didn't hear from any of the pastors.
那时她们不太熟，但珍告诉我丽贝卡的信息让她能够向自己承认她可能会堕胎，如果她真的这么做了也没关系。最终，珍选择了终止妊娠。事后，在教会，珍没有从任何牧师那里得到任何问候。
Summit didn't want to comment on this specific situation. But they said, in general, they aim for their ministry to be shaped by the approach of Jesus who went to people in crisis. Jen didn't feel like she could have a straight conversation with her small group. Sometimes, she just told people she'd lost the baby, letting them think it was a miscarriage.
“峰会”教堂不想对此具体情况发表评论。但他们说，总的来说，他们旨在使他们的事工以耶稣那种走向危机中的人的方式为蓝本。珍觉得她无法和小组进行直接的对话。有时，她只是告诉人们她流产了，让大家以为是自然流产。
Rebecca saw this and felt sad that Jen didn't feel like she could be honest. Rebecca believed church should be the place where people who are hurting can find comfort and a community to walk alongside them. She was disappointed that Summit could be so cold, especially in Jen's case, where it wasn't even a choice between a healthy baby and an abortion, between life and death.
丽贝卡看到这一点，为珍无法坦诚相待感到难过。丽贝卡相信教会应该是一个受伤的人可以找到安慰和同行社区的地方。她很失望“峰会”教堂会如此冷漠，尤其是在珍的情况中，这甚至不是在健康婴儿和堕胎之间、在生命和死亡之间的选择。
The baby was likely going to die. And so here we are in a situation where it was death and death. And there's no real choice there. It's just-- it is what it is. And so that really changed my view on abortion.
孩子很可能会死。所以我们现在处于一个死亡与死亡的情况。那里没有真正的选择。它只是——事情就是这样。所以这确实改变了我对堕胎的看法。
Rebecca understood why Jen chose to have an abortion, and believes she should have the right to do it. This idea would have been unthinkable to her only a few years earlier. She still struggled with the thought that healthy women with viable pregnancies would choose to terminate. But she also believes she couldn't know exactly what their reasons were, and it wasn't up to her to dictate someone else's decision.
丽贝卡理解珍为什么选择堕胎，并认为她应该有权这么做。这个想法在仅仅几年前对她来说是不可想象的。她仍然在挣扎于这样一个想法：拥有健康胎儿的健康女性会选择终止妊娠。但她也相信她无法确切知道她们的原因是什么，这不是她能左右他人决定的。
She decided to share all of this in a blog post-- a post that her family, and friends, and many online followers would see. It was scary. Rebecca worried that people would think she wasn't a Christian anymore. She wrote, quote, "I am an evangelical, pro-life, registered Republican who believes Roe v. Wade doesn't need to be overturned in an effort to decrease abortions. I chose life for two babies knowing they would die, and I do not believe that should be a choice women are forced into making."
她决定在博客文章中分享所有这些——她的家人、朋友和许多在线关注者都会看到的一篇帖子。这很可怕。丽贝卡担心人们会认为她不再是基督徒了。她写道，“我是一个福音派、反堕胎、注册共和党人，我认为‘罗诉韦德案’不需要为了减少堕胎而被推翻。我为两个明知会死去的婴儿选择了生命，我不认为那是女性被迫做出的选择。”
And then once I hit Publish, I was just like, OK, here we go. Because I knew there was going to be some sort of backlash.
然后一旦我按下发布，我就想，好的，我们开始吧。因为我知道会有某种反弹。
Did you get pastors trashing you? What kind of feedback were you getting?
有牧师抨击你吗？你得到了什么样的反馈？
"Jezebel, pro-abortionist, liberal."
“耶洗别（荡妇）、支持堕胎者、自由派。”
When you hear somebody calling you a Jezebel, what do you think they're trying to say to you?
当你听到有人称呼你为耶洗别时，你认为他们想对你说什么？
Like, a non-biblical woman, I think, is what they were trying to get across. Somebody who is controversial, non-biblical, somebody who should be kind of cast aside. I'm just saying, we don't know everyone's circumstances, and we can't force women to make a decision.
我觉得他们是想表达，一个非圣经的女性。一个有争议的、不符合圣经的人，一个应该被摒弃的人。我只是说，我们不知道每个人的具体情况，我们不能强迫女性做出决定。
So you felt like the fact that you had, with your own life, chosen to do this really, really, really hard thing based on your convictions basically counted for nothing after you came out and said that you supported legal abortion.
所以你觉得事实上你用自己的生命，根据你的信念做出了这件非常、非常、非常困难的事，在你出来说支持合法堕胎后，基本上就没有任何意义了？
Yes. So some people-- some people even told me I didn't do enough, that I should have had them all-- had the babies resuscitated. And I should have done all of the surgeries possible and all of the interventions possible, because I didn't do enough.
是的。所以有些人——有些人甚至告诉我我做得不够，我应该让她们全部——让婴儿接受复苏。我应该进行所有可能的手术和干预，因为我做得不够。
One evangelical blog wrote a couple of posts about Rebecca, deriding her as a, quote, "very confused person." Other bloggers screenshotted comments she made on Twitter and sent them to her pastor in her church, trying to prove that she wasn't a faithful Christian. Her pastor was a big deal in the evangelical world, and bloggers started attacking him just for being associated with her.
一个福音派博客写了几篇关于丽贝卡的帖子，嘲笑她是一个“非常困惑的人”。其他博主截屏了她在推特上发表的评论并发送给她教会的牧师，试图证明她不是一个忠实的基督徒。她的牧师在福音派世界中是个大人物，博主们开始攻击他，仅仅因为他与她有联系。
They wanted Rebecca kicked out of her church. That didn't happen, and Summit leaders say they get attacked online all the time. They tend to ignore nasty comments rather than responding to them directly. But to Rebecca, it felt conspicuous that Summit leaders never reached out or stepped up to defend her.
他们希望丽贝卡被赶出教会。那并没有发生，“峰会”教堂的领导人说他们一直受到在线攻击。他们倾向于无视讨厌的评论而不是直接回应。但对丽贝卡来说，“峰会”教堂的领导人从未联系或站出来为她辩护，这显得非常明显。
After everything that happened, Rebecca spent months agonizing over whether she and her family should even stay at Summit. It wasn't just the abortion issue. There was other stuff too. In particular, they didn't think the predominantly white world of Summit would be a good place to raise Aben, who's Black. Rebecca and Josh are white. They finally left last winter. Rebecca still strongly identifies as a Christian. And she's still close with her small group. But she's unsure where her place in the Christian world should be.
在发生这一切之后，丽贝卡花了几个月时间苦恼她和家人是否应该继续留在“峰会”。不仅仅是堕胎问题。还有其他事情。特别是，他们认为“峰会”绝大多数是白人的世界不适合抚养阿本，他是黑人。丽贝卡和乔什是白人。他们去年冬天终于离开了。丽贝卡仍然强烈认同自己是基督徒。她和她的小组仍然很亲密。但她不确定她在基督教世界中的位置应该在哪里。
While it feels hard to not be the pro-life darling that I once was, I feel like, it almost feels like churches and stuff don't know what to do with me. They don't know where to put me.
虽然不能再做曾经的那个反堕胎宠儿感觉很艰难，我觉得，几乎感觉教会之类的地方不知道该怎么对待我。他们不知道该把我放在哪里。
When it comes to abortion, Rebecca says she's personally pro-life. When she looks at her ultrasound screen at work, she still sees a human being. But she's less sure than she once was that life begins at conception.
谈到堕胎，丽贝卡说她个人是反堕胎的。当她在工作中看向超声波屏幕时，她仍然看到一个人类。但她比过去更不确定生命是否始于受孕。
I was talking about this with a friend recently, who's also very similar to me. I do feel like there's a lot of us out there who are kind of in between, and we just don't know which side to go to. Because we don't fit in the pro-life movement. We don't fit the pro-choice movement. We're kind of in the middle, and we see good in both, and that we don't know if they will ever mesh or if they will just go further apart.
我最近和一位朋友谈过这个，她也和我非常相似。我确实觉得外面有很多像我们这样处于中间地带的人，我们只是不知道该倒向哪一边。因为我们不属于反堕胎运动。我们也不属于支持堕胎运动。我们处于中间，我们两边都看到了美好之处，我们不知道它们是否会融合，或者它们是否会渐行渐远。
In all my years of reporting on abortion, this is the one thing that struck me over and over again. Most people are actually like Rebecca and her friend, caught between pro-life and pro-choice in some way or another. Polls show that most Americans think abortion should be legal in some form. But when it comes to spelling out the exact circumstances of when it should be allowed, or the morals of it, people are much more ambivalent. Most of us land in a gray area.
在我报道堕胎的所有岁月里，这是一次又一次打动我的一件事。大多数人实际上就像丽贝卡和她的朋友，在某种程度上被夹在反堕胎和支持堕胎之间。民意调查显示大多数美国人认为堕胎应该以某种形式合法。但当谈到说明允许堕胎的具体情况，或其道德性时，人们更矛盾。我们大多数人落入了一个灰色地带。
And in this moment, where the Supreme Court is about to make decisions that could dramatically change abortion in the United States, it's useful to remember that most people, most experiences, have never really fit into a neat binary. When you're trying to figure out what the right thing to do is, it's not as simple as picking which team you're on. It's way more murky and complicated than that.
在这个最高法院即将做出可能极大地改变美国堕胎问题的决定的时刻，记住大多数人、大多数经历从未真正符合整齐的二元对立是很有用的。当你试图弄清楚什么是正确的事情时，这不像选择你站在哪一边那么简单。它远比那要阴暗和复杂。
So do you feel, having gone through everything that you did, do you still feel like that was God's plan for you?
那么，经历了你所经历的一切，你仍然觉得那是上帝为你制定的计划吗？
Yeah. I feel like there's a reason why it all happened, whether I see it or not. I don't feel like it was a mistake at all. I do feel-- I mean, I still feel anger to this day that it even happened, period. But I don't feel any regret. I feel like it was the right choice for me. I would do it all over again. I would choose life for Cora and Layla, as much as I know that it caused pain, because they were my daughters, and I loved them, and I cared for them.
是的。我觉得无论我是否能看到，这一切的发生都有理由。我不觉得那是个错误。我确实觉得——我的意思是，直到今天我仍然对这一切的发生感到愤怒。但我没有任何遗憾。我觉得那对我来说是正确的选择。我愿意重新做一遍。我会为科拉和莱拉选择生命，尽管我知道这造成了痛苦，因为她们是我的女儿，我爱她们，我关心她们。
And similarly, I'm not getting pregnant, because I know that I would have to have another baby that could have another diagnosis. And I don't want to put myself in that situation where I might have to choose. I might not choose life. I don't know.
同样地，我不再怀孕，因为我知道我将不得不再生一个可能会有其他诊断的孩子。我不想让自己陷入那种我可能不得不做出选择的境地。我可能不会选择生命。我不知道。
For all of the clarity Rebecca has come to over the last few years, she's ended up with much less certainty about her life and life's big questions. She never got her picture-perfect minivan full of kids. This grieves her, leaves her feeling unsettled. But maybe that's where God meets us, she thinks, in that broken, uncertain place.
尽管丽贝卡在过去几年里获得的所有清晰度，她最终对生活和生活中的大问题却少了许多确定性。她没能得到她那张装满孩子的完美小货车。这让她悲伤，让她感到不安。但也许那就是上帝遇见我们的地方，她想，在那个破碎、不确定的地方。
Emma Green. She's a staff writer at The New Yorker. She reported this story in collaboration with The Atlantic and the podcast The Experiment, where this story is also appearing. Coming up, two people disagreeing about something so big, so fundamental, so important in their lives, but I have to say, doing it in the nicest possible way. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
艾玛·格林。她是《纽约客》的特约撰稿人。她与《大西洋月刊》和播客《实验》合作报道了这个故事，这个故事也出现在《实验》中。接下来，两个人在生活中在某些如此重大、如此根本、如此重要的事情上存在分歧，但我必须说，他们以最友好的方式处理了它。一分钟后，来自芝加哥公共广播电台，我们的节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, "But I Did Everything Right," stories where people do what they have been told is best, they do what they think is right, and it doesn't come out the way they thought. We've arrived at Act Two of our program-- Act Two, "Brian and Peg."
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目，“但我做的一切都是对的”，讲述人们按照被告知的最佳方式去做、他们做他们认为正确的事情，却并没有得到他们预想的结果的故事。我们已经到达了节目的第二幕——第二幕，“布莱恩和佩格”。
So when we started to put together today's program about trying to do everything right and where that leads, I remember this conversation that I had this past May with two people, Brian and Peg, who had tried to do everything right. The day I met them was also the day that I learned about this disagreement they have. This was in an outdoor amphitheater in a public park in Queens.
所以当我们开始安排今天关于尝试做一切正确的事以及它会导致什么后果的节目时，我记得去年五月我和两个人，布莱恩和佩格，进行的谈话，他们试图做一切正确的事。我见到他们的那天，也是我了解到他们之间的分歧的那天。这是在纽约皇后区一个公共公园的露天剧场。
So Brian, can I record you for a little bit as you're organizing things?
所以布莱恩，在你整理东西时我可以录一会儿吗？
[? It's cool. ?]
[? 挺酷的。 ?]
Is that OK?
可以吗？
Just understand that I'm not very organized. [LAUGHS]
要知道我不太擅长整理。[笑]
That day, Brian, Walter, and a bunch of other volunteers were setting up a local memorial event for people who had died of COVID in Queens in New York, which was especially hard-hit by the pandemic early on. The memorial was Brian's idea, to have an event where portraits of Queens residents who died of COVID would be placed on empty chairs in this amphitheater. People who loved them would gather around. There were speeches remembering those who passed.
那天，布莱恩、沃尔特和其他一群志愿者正在为纽约皇后区死于新冠的人们筹备当地的纪念活动，皇后区在疫情初期受创尤为严重。纪念活动是布莱恩的想法，在一个活动中，死于新冠的皇后区居民的肖像将被放置在这个露天剧场的空椅子上。爱他们的人们会聚集在周围。会有悼念逝者的演讲。
When we first came up with this idea, I mean, we did not imagine the scope of what it is today. We thought there was just going to be a few of us in the park with a few benches, maybe 20 or 30 of us.
当我们最初想到这个主意时，我的意思是，我们并没有想到今天它的规模。我们以为公园里只会有一小群人，几条长椅，大概20或30个人。
How quickly did it grow?
它成长得有多快？
It took off. All of the tickets were gone in 25 minutes. Yep, 200 tickets.
它火了。所有的票在25分钟内就卖完了。没错，200张票。
I'm sorry. I'm going to bother you one more time. If we can just raise it--
抱歉。我要再打扰你一次。如果我们能把它抬高——
An energetic, gray-haired woman interrupts us. That's Peg.
一位精力充沛、头发灰白的女士打断了我们。那是佩格。
But if you can just raise it, it would help.
但如果你能把它抬高，会有帮助的。
Have to do manual labor now. [LAUGHS]
现在得做体力活了。[笑]
But get that done first.
但先把那个弄完。
Mom's always the boss.
妈妈总是老板。
Is that your mom?
那是你妈妈吗？
Yes, that's my mother.
是的，那是我母亲。
What's been your role in organizing this?
你在组织这次活动中的角色是什么？
[LAUGHS] What's been my role? Oh, that's a good question. I kind of help Brian flesh out his ideas. We discussed/argued over many things. It's, why don't you try this? I don't know if that's going to work. Why don't we do it this way? Back and forth. I guess, in some ways, I'm the more practical person.
[笑] 我的角色是什么？哦，这真是个好问题。我算是帮布莱恩充实他的想法。我们讨论/争论过许多事情。是你为什么不试试这个？我不知道那是否会起作用。为什么我们不这样做？来来回回。我想，在某些方面，我是更实际的那个人。
Peg's practical experience running things includes 30 years as director of religious education for a couple of Catholic churches, supervising over 20 teachers, hundreds of kids. Her husband, John, Brian's dad, got COVID right at the beginning, April 2020, and he died a few weeks later.
佩格经营事务的实践经验包括在几家天主教堂担任了30年的宗教教育主任，监管20多名教师、数百名孩子。她的丈夫约翰，布莱恩的父亲，在2020年4月刚开始时就得了新冠，几周后去世了。
And of course, he's right over there today, and-- right here.
当然，他今天就在那儿，而且——就在这儿。
Oh, right here, right up front.
哦，就在这儿，就在前面。
Yeah, it's my husband of 57 years.
是的，这是我结婚57年的丈夫。
Wow.
哇。
So-- so that's him. Yeah.
所以——那是他。是的。
In the portrait, he's wearing a New York Mets hat and a plaid shirt.
照片中，他戴着一顶纽约大都会队的帽子，穿着一件格子衬衫。
So it's been very difficult. It's one of those things that [SIGHS] you just have to take baby steps to get over.
所以一直非常艰难。这是那些[叹气]你必须一步一个脚印才能走出来的事情之一。
Which brings me to the thing this story is actually about-- this disagreement she has with her son Brian. Brian has told other reporters, and he's told me, that he was wracked with guilt with the knowledge that he gave his dad COVID. Brian lives in the apartment upstairs from his parents in kind of a traditional Queens two-family house.
这就引出了这个故事真正的主题——她和儿子布莱恩之间的分歧。布莱恩告诉过其他记者，也告诉过我，他因为知道自己传染给父亲新冠而备受内疚折磨。布莱恩住在父母楼上的公寓里，那是一种传统的皇后区双户住宅。
And when COVID happened, he would go out each day to his job at the MTA. He would ride in the subway. He would work in the tunnels with other people. And he believes he brought home the virus to his dad. Peg is certain he's wrong, that her husband John did not get COVID from Brian. In fact, it was the other way around. John got sick first. And Brian--
当新冠发生时，他每天出去MTA工作。他会乘坐地铁。他会和其他人在隧道里工作。他相信他把病毒带回了家给了他父亲。佩格确信他错了，她的丈夫约翰不是从布莱恩那传染的。事实上，刚好相反。约翰先病了。而布莱恩——
OK, Brian got sick-- I am positive that he got it the night that he took John to the hospital. From sitting next to John-- well, first of all, he had to help his father down the stairs into the car. And then he sat in the car and drove him first to the urgent care, and then into Manhattan, to Mount Sinai.
好的，布莱恩病了——我确信他是那天他带约翰去医院的晚上感染的。因为坐在约翰旁边——好吧，首先，他必须帮他父亲下楼进车。然后他坐在车里开车先去了急诊，然后去了曼哈顿的西奈山医院。
And you think that's when Brian got it?
你认为那就是布莱恩感染的时候？
I'm sure that's how Brian came down with it. Because two days-- three days later, he tested positive. And he had not been sick the whole time. And even though he lived upstairs from us, in an apartment upstairs, he used to come home from work, go upstairs. And sometimes John would say, he didn't even stop in to say hello. And I said, I know that. He's taking a shower. He'll be down in a few minutes.
我确信布莱恩就是那么感染的。因为两天——三天后，他的测试呈阳性。而他之前一直没生病。即使他住在我们楼上的公寓里，他下班回家，也会上楼。有时约翰会说，他连停下来打个招呼都没有。我说，我知道。他在洗澡。他几分钟后会下来。
And he'd come down with mask on, with gloves. I mean, he was being super careful. And I really don't think that he got it any other way but from John. And I don't know how John or I got COVID. And believe me, I've stayed awake long enough at night trying to figure it out.
他会戴着口罩、戴着手套下来。我的意思是，他非常小心。我真的不认为他除了从约翰那里感染外还有其他途径。我不知道约翰或我是怎么感染新冠的。相信我，我熬过无数个夜晚试图弄清楚它。
But Brian worries that he gave it to his dad.
但布莱恩担心他传染给了他父亲。
He worries he did, but I'm positive he didn't. I'm sorry, I keep--
他担心是他，但我确信不是。抱歉，我一直在——
No, no, no.
不，不，不。
I talk with my hands, and I keep hitting your mic. I'm sorry.
我说话爱手舞足蹈，一直撞到你的麦克风。抱歉。
That's interesting, though, that he's chosen to believe that he's to blame.
不过这很有趣，他选择相信他是罪魁祸首。
I know. I know that. But I'm positive that he's not. I mean, maybe I'm wrong, but I'm positive that he's not. Because for John to have been that sick to go in the hospital, he must have gotten it days and days earlier. And then why wasn't Brian sick until after John went to the hospital?
我知道。我知道。但我确信他不是。我的意思是，也许我错了，但我确信他不是。因为约翰病得那么重去医院，他一定得在几天前就感染了。那为什么布莱恩直到约翰去医院后才生病？
Why do you think he thinks that he gave it to him?
你觉得他为什么认为是他传染的？
I just think it's-- that's the way he is, that he feels he gave it to him.
我只是觉得——他就是那种人，他觉得是他传染的。
It's funny. I've heard about people who blame themselves. It's almost like it gives him more control of the situation if he thinks he was to blame. It wasn't just, like, a bolt of lightning or something hittting him.
这很有趣。我听说过人们责怪自己。感觉就像如果他认为是他负责，这给了他更多的控制感。这不仅仅像是闪电击中了他之类的。
Right. It could be. I don't know.
对。可能是。我不知道。
Of course, so many families are in this situation, wondering how somebody they love got COVID. Why did Brian choose to believe this about his dad? Why wasn't he convinced by his mom? He was too busy, that particular day, to have a real conversation with me about the whole thing, but I dropped by his house later. His dad, John, was a history buff, and a Civil War expert and researcher. And by the doorbell, there's an example of John's sense of humor. There's a bronze plaque that reads, "On this site in 1897, nothing happened."
当然，这么多家庭处于这种状况，想知道他们爱的人是怎么得了新冠的。为什么布莱恩选择相信关于他父亲的这一说法？为什么他没有被他母亲说服？那天他太忙了，没法和我进行真正的交流，但我后来顺便去了他家。他的父亲约翰是个历史迷，也是个内战专家和研究员。在门铃旁边，有一个约翰幽默感的例子。有一块青铜牌匾写着，“1897年在此处，什么也没发生。”
Brian told me, back when his dad first died, he felt so guilty. Since he got COVID too, he says, it really hit home what his dad must have gone through to have a case that was even worse than his. And he says he thought about it all the time. How would he let this happen to his dad? And what made it especially hard? They were doing everything right, being as careful as they knew how.
布莱恩告诉我，当他父亲刚去世时，他感到如此内疚。自从他也得了新冠，他说，这让他真正体会到他父亲病情比他更严重时一定经历过什么。他说他一直在想这件事。他怎么能让这发生在他父亲身上？而且特别难受的是什么？他们做的一切都是对的，按照他们知道的最谨慎的方式去做。
We thought we were doing everything correct. I mean, everything that the CDC said-- my mom watches CNN on a good day. She was watching it double during that time. And everything they said, we would wipe everything down. We had bleach outside. We had wipes outside. We and everything. And yet he still got it.
我们以为我们做的一切都是正确的。我的意思是，疾控中心说的一切——我妈妈状态好时会看CNN。她在那个时期看了双倍的节目。他们说的一切，我们都会擦拭干净。我们在外面放了漂白剂。我们在外面放了擦拭巾。我们一切都做了。然而他还是得了。
Remember March 2020, when all this was so new, and we were figuring out how to deal with it?
还记得2020年3月，当这一切都如此新鲜，我们正在弄清楚如何处理它的时候吗？
And I was the one who was shopping for the family, and I would separate their groceries. [LAUGHS] We had a grocery drop-off procedure. And we discussed it at length, about how we were going to do this. Through text messages, we had meetings where I would be at the top of the stairs, and they would be at the bottom. And we'd go through about, I'm going to drop the stuff off for you. I'm going to leave it there. Do not come out until I tell you that I'm upstairs.
我是那个为家庭购物的人，我会分开他们的杂货。[笑] 我们有个杂货投递程序。我们详细讨论过我们将如何做这件事。通过短信，我们开了会，我会在楼梯顶端，他们在底部。我们会过一遍，我要为你放下东西。我会把它留在那里。直到我告诉你我在楼上了，不要出来。
And that's what we did. And then they would come out. My mother would come out, and she would wipe everything down. And we had a whole decontamination station set up in the front of the house. I did the whole gloves in the store, and not touching the phone. And I even had, in my car, a bottle of water and a container of soap that, more than once, I would just wash my hands in the parking lot before coming home. And we thought we were doing everything correct.
我们就那样做了。然后他们会出来。我母亲会出来，她会把一切都擦干净。我们在房子前面设置了一个完整的去污站。我在商店里戴了全套手套，不碰手机。我甚至在车里放了一瓶水和一罐肥皂，不止一次，我会在回到家前在停车场把手洗了。我们以为我们做的一切都是正确的。
So when you picture giving it to your dad, what's the scenario that you run-- that runs through your head?
所以当你想象传染给你父亲时，你脑海中运行的情景是什么？
You don't know what happened. I mean, I can tell you that my dad didn't leave the house, and I was the only one going out. So my mom couldn't have given it to him. My kids didn't see him, so they couldn't have given it to him. So I was the only kind of link at that point. So of course, it had to have come from me. How else did he get it?
你不知道发生了什么。我的意思是，我可以告诉你我父亲没离开过房子，而我是唯一一个出去的人。所以我妈不可能传染给他。我的孩子们没见过他，所以他们不可能传染给他。所以在那一点上我是唯一的链接。所以当然，它必须来自我。不然他还能从哪儿感染？
Oh, wait. I hadn't put that together. You're the only one in the whole house who's coming in and out?
哦，等等。我还没把这联系起来。你是整栋房子里唯一出入的人？
Yeah. Yeah, since St. Patrick's Day-- since even before St. Patrick's Day.
是的。是的，从圣帕特里克节开始——甚至在圣帕特里克节之前。
Again, this is 2020, very beginning of lockdown.
再说一次，这是2020年，封锁的最开始。
My parents did not leave this house since the beginning of March. And I was the only one coming in and out.
我父母从3月初开始就没有离开过这所房子。而我是唯一一个进进出出的人。
So you're the only contact with the outside world.
所以你是唯一的外部接触者。
Yep. Yeah.
是的。是的。
So if the virus got to him at all, you were the only one who could have brought it in.
所以如果病毒根本到达了他那里，你是唯一一个可能带进去的人。
Right. That's why I keep thinking that. Yeah, because I'm the only one going out.
对。这就是我一直这么想的原因。是的，因为我是唯一一个出去的人。
I've got to say, it's really hard to see any way around that. Brian knows all of his mom's arguments, that when you look at the dates, that Brian started showing symptoms after his dad got sick, so Brian must have gotten COVID from his dad and not the other way around.
我得说，很难看到绕过这一点的任何方法。布莱恩知道他母亲所有的论点，即当你查看日期时，布莱恩是在他父亲生病后才表现出症状的，所以布莱恩一定是先从他父亲那里感染了新冠，而不是相反。
Yeah, I mean, her accounting is definitely correct. I guess what it doesn't explain is, it still doesn't explain how he got it. In my mind, it still comes back to the fact that I was bringing everything in. So it's not even so much if I personally had it in me. Because again, we did not connect, so we were not together. So it wasn't that I breathed it on him.
是的，我的意思是，她的核算绝对是正确的。我想它不能解释的是，它仍然不能解释他是怎么感染的。在我脑海里，它仍然回到这样一个事实：我把一切带进来了。所以即使不是我自己带着它。因为再次重申，我们没有接触，所以我们没在一起。所以并不是我对他呼吸了它。
But bringing everything into the house, I worry about, did I grab the wrong lemonade? Did somebody sneeze on this lemonade before I brought it in? And he got it, and he picked it up, and that's where he got it? I'm not saying she's wrong. We just don't know.
但把一切带进房子，我担心的是，我是不是拿错了柠檬水？是不是有人在我带进去之前对着这个柠檬水打喷嚏了？他得了，他捡了起来，这就是他感染的地方？我不是说她错了。我们只是不知道。
That's funny. You're not saying she's wrong. She is definitely saying you're wrong.
这很有趣。你不是说她错了。她是绝对说你错了。
[LAUGHS] That's my mom. Yup, that's Mom. But I can also tell Mom also doesn't want this hanging over me. A mother's first job is to always console her child, and help her child think the best, and whatnot.
[笑] 那是我妈。没错，那是妈妈。但我也能看出妈妈也不想让这阴影笼罩我。母亲的首要职责是总是安慰她的孩子，帮助她的孩子往最好的方面想，诸如此类。
So I'm not saying that she's saying this just to help me get over it. But of course, she's never going to say-- even if she knew definitively, she is never going to say, oh, you did it. Never going to say that. She's going to say, Brian, you don't know that you did it. There's nothing to prove it. Don't beat yourself up about it. Let it go. And that's the way it's always going to be.
所以我不是说她这么说是为了帮我走出来。但当然，她永远不会说——即使她确切地知道，她也永远不会说，哦，是你干的。永远不会那么说。她会说，布莱恩，你不知道是你干的。没有证据证明它。别为此折磨自己。把它放下。这就是一切将永远的样子。
In the end, of course, they'll never know. His mom can believe what she wants. Brian will believe what he believes. But this is really a classic situation, eventually, with something you can't answer. You think, and you think, and you think.
最终，当然，他们永远不会知道。他母亲可以选择她想相信的。布莱恩会相信他相信的。但这确实是一个经典的、最终的情况，对于你无法回答的事情。你思考，你思考，你再思考。
It gets to the point where you just can't think about it anymore.
它到了你无法再思考它的地步。
At that point, the only comfort you have is, if you did screw up, it wasn't for lack of trying. Peg said to me that at some point, you have to let it go because you did everything you could. You did everything right.
在那个时刻，你唯一的安慰是，如果你确实搞砸了，那也不是因为你没尝试。佩格告诉我，在某个时候，你必须放下它，因为你已经尽了一切努力。你做的一切都是对的。
Act 3, "Bought the Farm." So we close out today's program about people trying to do the right thing with something that happened to one of our staffers here, David Kestenbaum, and his family. They got this kid's toy, an educational toy that's been popular for decades. And his family followed the instructions that came with it to the letter. And they ended up learning a lesson I feel pretty confident the manufacturers did not intend. Here's David.
第三幕，“买了农场”。所以我们结束今天关于人们努力做正确的事的节目，提到了一件发生在我们的一位工作人员大卫·克斯滕鲍姆和他家人身上的事。他们得到了这个儿童玩具，一个流行了几十年的益智玩具。他的家人严格遵循了随附的说明书。最终他们学到了一课，我相当确信制造商并没有打算教导这一课。这是大卫。
The ant farm was a gift to our kids from their grandparents. We were all excited for it-- though if I'm honest, maybe mostly me. I'd suggested it. I never had one growing up, but they seemed so cool. It's basically two sheets of see-through plastic, a half inch apart, made it into this frame. You get a bunch of sand to put in it. And then when you mail in the coupon, two tubes of live ants come to your house in the mail.
蚂蚁农场是祖父母送给我们孩子们的礼物。我们都很兴奋——尽管说实话，可能主要是因为我。我提议的。我从小就没玩过，但它们看起来太酷了。它基本上是两张透明塑料板，相隔半英寸，做成了一个框。你会得到一堆沙子放进去。然后当你寄出优惠券，两管活蚂蚁会通过邮件送到你家。
The promotional material read, "See the amazing behavior of live ants," with a photo of the ants digging elaborate tunnels. "Clean tunneling sand," it said, and also, "2016 National Parenting Product Awards winner." So we set it up, put the ants in as directed. There were, like, 100 of them.
宣传材料上写着，“观看活蚂蚁的神奇行为”，配有蚂蚁挖掘复杂隧道的一张照片。“干净的隧道沙”，它说，还有，“2016年全国育儿产品奖得主”。所以我们安装了它，按指示放入了蚂蚁。大约有100只。
The instructions say to feed them a crumb every week and add a few drops of water now and then. And at first, it was amazing. The ants got to work running in all different directions, over top of each other, picking up little bits of sand in their jaws. It was this chaotic construction site. Here's a little daily diary based on photos I took at the time. "March 9, we put them in. 10:50 PM, digging first exploratory tunnels. Energetic, fast-moving. Digging, digging, digging. March 10, morning, 8:00 AM, they made a loop, connected two tunnels, reached the bottom."
说明书说每周喂它们一块面包屑，偶尔加几滴水。起初，它太神奇了。蚂蚁们开始工作，朝各个方向奔跑，在彼此身上爬行，在下颚里叼着小沙粒。这是一个混乱的建筑工地。这是一份基于我当时拍的照片的日常日记。“3月9日，我们放入了它们。晚上10:50，挖掘第一批探索性隧道。精力充沛，移动迅速。挖掘，挖掘，挖掘。3月10日，上午8:00，它们做了一个环，连接了两条隧道，到达了底部。”
I shot a time-lapse video of them working, like you'd see on a TV nature special. It really was like a secret cross-section of an anthill. But then came the thing they don't touch on it all in the brochure. And for us, it really became the main thing. Later that day, 1:25 PM, our second day with the ant farm. There's a photo on my phone-- close-up of a dead ant buried in the sand. And a few days later, this video I happened to take--
我拍了一段它们工作的延时视频，就像你在电视自然专题片中看到的那样。它确实像是一个蚂蚁窝的秘密横截面。但接下来发生的是手册中完全没有触及的事情。对我们来说，它确实变成了主要的事情。那天晚些时候，下午1:25，我们玩蚂蚁农场的第二天。我手机里有一张照片——一张埋在沙子里死去的蚂蚁的特写镜头。几天后，这段我碰巧拍下的视频——
And that's where the bodies are, in there. And over here. [GROANS]
那些尸体就在那里。在这边。[呻吟]
Not only were some of the ants dying, but the other ants were picking up dead ones and carrying them, like soldiers in battle. And they'd been taking the bodies and body pieces-- there's an ant carrying another's head-- over into the corner and burying them. It was this mass grave.
不仅有些蚂蚁在死亡，而且其他蚂蚁在拾起死蚂蚁，扛着它们，就像战场上的士兵。它们一直在把尸体和身体碎片——有一只蚂蚁扛着另一只的头——搬到角落里埋葬。这是一个乱葬岗。
[GROANS]
[呻吟]
It seemed kind of outrageous that this is a kid's toy. I mean, I suppose death is part of other kid's games, but it's imaginary. This was not imaginary, and it really was hard to watch. Every morning, I'd look at the ant farm sitting on the counter in our kitchen. Day after day, they'd carry the new body to the corner and add them to the pile.
这作为一个儿童玩具似乎有点过分。我的意思是，我假设死亡是其他儿童游戏的一部分，但那是虚构的。这可不是虚构的，看这个真的很难受。每天早上，我都会看着放在我们厨房台面上的蚂蚁农场。日复一日，它们会把新尸体搬到角落里，加到堆里。
That guy is still a little alive, yeah. [GROANS]
那个家伙还有点活着，是啊。[呻吟]
The ant farm was basically a six-week exercise in watching things die. Eventually, there were just two ants left, and they did not seem well. They were having trouble walking.
蚂蚁农场基本上是一个为期六周的观看东西死亡的练习。最终，只剩下两只蚂蚁，它们看起来状态不好。走路困难。
Our kids honestly were sort of fine with this. Our younger son, who is eight, said, this is horrible. But I think mostly because he had in his mind that they would be pets, like a dog or something. His brother, who is one year older, nine, said, we could just buy more. They stopped looking at it and went on with their lives. But my wife and I felt terrible. The ant farm made us anxious. We felt responsible, like maybe we'd failed the ants. But also just so much death. There on our kitchen counter every morning, the mass grave.
我们的孩子诚实地说对这个还算可以接受。我们8岁的小儿子说，这太可怕了。但我认为主要是因为他心里认为它们会是宠物，像狗之类的。他的哥哥，大一岁，9岁，说，我们可以再买。它们不再看了，继续生活。但我妻子和我感觉很糟糕。蚂蚁农场让我们感到焦虑。我们感到有责任，就像也许我们辜负了蚂蚁。但也太多死亡了。每天早上都在我们的厨房台面上，那个乱葬岗。
What exactly were we looking at? What was this kid's toy supposed to be teaching us? So I called up a scientist, Deborah Gordon at Stanford, who has studied these kinds of ants, to ask, what the hell? She calmly explained the mass graves. She says, they're actually middens, meaning garbage heaps. The ants aren't burying their dead as much as taking out the trash. She says this may have evolved because dead ants sometimes carry disease.
我们到底在看什么？这个儿童玩具应该是教给我们什么的？所以我打电话给斯坦福大学的黛博拉·戈登科学家，她研究过这些蚂蚁，问，到底怎么回事？她平静地解释了乱葬岗。她说，它们实际上是垃圾堆。蚂蚁不是在埋葬死者，而是在清扫垃圾。她说这可能是进化出来的，因为死蚂蚁有时会携带疾病。
Well, they take the dead to the furthest possible place, which ends up being the corner. If you gave them a really large space to move around, they'd take them even further away. I've seen them go out on the foraging trails 10, 15 meters away and dump the ant.
嗯，它们把死者带到尽可能远的地方，最终变成了角落。如果你给它们很大的空间移动，它们会把它们带得更远。我见过它们在离巢10、15米远的觅食路径上抛弃死蚂蚁。
Wow.
哇。
So those are ones that I think must be infected in some way. That's a lot of work.
所以我想那些一定是某种方式被感染的。那是大量的工作。
What are they dying of in here? Do they die of old age? Is their heart-- do they have a heart? Like, the way a heart is only good for however many beats. What fails in them?
它们在里面死于什么？它们是老死吗？它们心脏——它们有心脏吗？就像心脏只对跳动次数有效的那样？什么在它们身上失效了？
I don't think anybody knows how ants die of old age.
我不认为有人知道蚂蚁是如何老死的。
Ants do have something like a heart, and a tiny brain. The ants in the farm, they're all females, she says. Males are only alive for a couple of weeks to mate. They have wings.
蚂蚁确实有类似于心脏的东西，还有一个微小的大脑。她说，农场里的蚂蚁全都是雌性的。雄性只活几周来交配。它们有翅膀。
One of the things I've come to appreciate about ants is how alien they are. And maybe the most alien thing about them is that they don't seem to get discouraged.
我开始欣赏蚂蚁的一点是它们是多么异类。也许它们身上最异类的事情是它们似乎不会感到气馁。
How do you see that in them?
你是怎么从中看出这一点的？
Well, I've done lots of mean things to ants in my time. One of the experiments that I did was to put out piles of toothpicks for them to clear away. And you can just keep putting out the toothpicks, and they keep taking them to the edge of the mound. And if more toothpicks show up, they just take more toothpicks.
嗯，我在我的时代对蚂蚁做过很多坏事。我做过的一个实验是为它们放一堆牙签让它们清理。你可以一直放牙签，它们就一直把它们带到堆的边缘。如果有更多牙签出现，它们就再带更多牙签。
And I've never seen an ant sort of sit down and say, oh, come on, not another toothpick. There's no way I'm doing this. They just keep doing things. And in fact, if you watch ants closely, a lot of what they do just doesn't work. I mean, if they were easily discouraged, they'd never get anywhere. It's very hard to watch ants without wanting to help them.
我从来没见过一只蚂蚁坐下来说，哦，算了吧，不是又一批牙签。我绝对不干这活了。它们只是继续做事情。事实上，如果你仔细观察蚂蚁，它们做的很多事情根本不起作用。我的意思是，如果它们容易气馁，它们永远走不到任何地方。看着蚂蚁而不产生帮助它们的冲动是非常困难的。
Have you ever done that?
你做过那样的事吗？
I used to try to help them, in the beginning. But I don't anymore, because I'm not very good at helping them. They respond mostly to smell. And so if you see the ants trying to carry something, and you try to carry it for them, as soon as you pick it up, you've changed the smell, and you've changed what it is for them.
起初我确实试图帮助它们。但我现在不那么做了，因为我不擅长帮助它们。它们主要对气味做出反应。所以如果你看到蚂蚁试图扛某样东西，而你试图帮它们扛，一旦你拿起来，你就改变了气味，你也改变了它对它们来说是什么。
The thing she told me that stuck with me most about what their lives are like in the little toy and farm is that their lives are pointless, because there is no queen. These are just worker ants separated from their colony in this fake little Truman Show world, where if they dig too far, they hit a plastic wall. In fact, she says, they're stuck in a little repeating loop, waiting for a thing that never happens.
她告诉我的关于它们在玩具小农场里生活的内容，最让我感触的一点是，它们的生活是毫无意义的，因为没有蚁后。这些只是与蚁群分离的工蚁，生活在这个假的“楚门的世界”里，如果它们挖得太深，就会碰到塑料墙。事实上，她说，它们被困在一个微小的循环中，等待着永远不会发生的事情。
She says basically, these ants are supposed to be going out, foraging for food, and bringing it back to the nest, and then waiting until they come into contact with enough other ants coming back before going out again. They can tell if an ant has been outside because the sun changes how they smell. But of course, there is no going out. No one leaves the ant farm.
她说基本上，这些蚂蚁应该是出去觅食，带回窝里，然后等到它们与足够多的其他蚂蚁接触后再出去。它们能辨别蚂蚁是否出去了，因为太阳会改变它们的气味。但当然，没有“出去”这回事。没人离开蚂蚁农场。
So they're probably in some kind of a feedback loop that isn't what they usually do.
所以它们可能处于某种不是它们通常行为的反馈循环中。
Because when they go up to another ant, they're never getting a signal that, oh, I've been out and I found food.
因为当它们走到另一只蚂蚁面前时，它们永远不会得到“哦，我出去了并且找到了食物”的信号。
And I found food, yeah.
我找到了食物，是啊。
I see. I wonder what the last ant is going to die of.
我明白了。我想知道最后一只蚂蚁会死于什么。
The last ant is just going to stand around, because nothing will happen to it that has any meaning.
最后一只蚂蚁只是会站在那里，因为不会有任何有意义的事情发生在它身上。
Knowing this somehow changed things for me. Toward the end of our time with the ants, the daily check-ins felt a little less like grim death watches. I found myself rooting for them and their meaningless lives. It was impressive, how they just kept going.
知道这一点某种程度上改变了我的看法。在我们陪伴蚂蚁的最后，每天的查看感觉少了一点像无情的死亡观。我发现自己为它们和它们毫无意义的生活加油。令人印象深刻的是，它们只是继续前进。
One day, we were sure it was over. That morning, I hadn't seen any motion at all on the ant farm. But then my son saw something down in the corner. There was one left-- the last ant. "What's it doing?" I asked. "It's doing what it needs to do," he said. I saw the ant again the next day, emerging from a tunnel, carrying a piece of sand in her jaw to nowhere.
有一天，我们确定一切都结束了。那天早上，我在蚂蚁农场上根本没看到任何动静。但后来我儿子看到了角落里有什么东西。剩下最后一只——最后一只蚂蚁。“它在干什么？”我问。“它在做它需要做的事，”他说。第二天我再次看到了那只蚂蚁，它从隧道里出来，在下颚里叼着一块沙子，不知去向。
David Kestenbaum. He's our program's senior editor.
大卫·克斯滕鲍姆。他是我们节目的高级编辑。
Our program was produced today by Aviva DeKornfeld and Chloee Weiner, with help from Diane Wu. The people who put together today's program include Bim Adewunmi, Elna Baker, Susan Burton, Sean Cole, Damien Graef, Miki Meek, Stowe Nelson, Katherine Rae Mondo, Alix Spiegel, Robyn Semien, Laura Starcheski, Jessica Soriano, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, and Julie Whitaker.
我们今天的节目由阿维娃·德科恩菲尔德和克洛伊·维纳制作，戴安·吴提供了帮助。负责今天节目的工作人员包括比姆·阿德温米、埃尔娜·贝克、苏珊·伯顿、肖恩·科尔、达米安·格雷夫、米基·米克、斯托·尼尔森、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多、阿利克斯·斯皮格尔、罗宾·塞米恩、劳拉·斯塔切斯基、杰西卡·索里亚诺、克里斯托弗·斯威塔拉、马特·蒂尔尼和朱莉·惠特克。
Managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman. Our senior editor is David Kestenbaum. Our executive editor is Emanuele Berry. Special thanks today to Eve Sneider, Gemma Bauer, Emily Patel, Aimee Baron, Katherine Wells, Emily Botein, Julia Longoria, Nick Baumann, Brent Beck of Grandpa Beck's Games, Nina Krstic, and Phil de Vries.
总编辑是萨拉·阿卜杜拉赫曼。我们的高级编辑是大卫·克斯滕鲍姆。我们的执行编辑是伊曼纽尔·贝里。今天特别感谢夏娃·斯奈德、杰玛·鲍尔、艾米丽·帕特尔、艾米·巴伦、凯瑟琳·威尔斯、艾米丽·博廷、朱莉娅·隆戈里亚、尼克·鲍曼、爷爷贝克游戏的布伦特·贝克、尼娜·克里斯蒂奇和菲尔·德·弗里斯。
Our website, thisamericanlife.org, where you can stream our archive of over 750 episodes for absolutely free. Also, there's videos, there's lists of favorite shows, tons of other stuff there. Again, thisamericanlife.org.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org，在那里你可以免费流媒体收听我们超过750集的档案。此外，还有视频，有最喜爱的节目列表，上面还有很多其他东西。再次重申，thisamericanlife.org。
This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, his family has the weirdest Halloween tradition I have ever heard of. Every year, they all dress up as Bruce Springsteen and the E Street Band and go trick or treating.
《美国生活》由PRX公共广播交易中心传送到公共广播电台。像往常一样，感谢我们节目的联合创始人，托雷·马拉蒂亚先生。你知道，他的家庭有我听说过的最奇怪的万圣节传统。每年，他们都装扮成布鲁斯·斯普林斯汀和E街乐队去玩“不给糖就捣蛋”。
Mom's always the boss.
妈妈总是老板。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。